there are two differences at least that
I see between the asteroid problem as
you've posed it and that climate change
problem first is the fact that you can't
see carbon dioxide it's a colorless non
toxic to humans at some concentration
gas on the other hand how would you feel
if everybody on the freeway every mile
they drove stopped open their windows
and dumped out a pound of trash that's
exactly what we do just you can't see
that pound of carbon dioxide trash that
comes out of everybody's tailpipe on
average every single mile we drive the
second thing is that if the asteroid
were absolutely hitting the earth we
would probably really respond but
there's some probability that it may get
by and then we always have to understand
the cost-benefit analysis of do we act
or not the same thing is true with
carbon dioxide emissions we don't
absolutely know what levels of carbon
dioxide are or are not quote safe and so
we get into actually in my opinion very
inappropriate discussion of whether or
not we should take action or not the
real issue is not whether we can prove
that climate change will or will not
occur within 10 or 20 or 30 years the
real issue is that we don't really know
for sure but we only get to do this
experiment once and if we get into a
situation that we don't like we can't do
anything about changing it back to where
it was this is not a situation of sound
science it is all about rolling the dice
once with the one plan
that we have